he can make an omelet without breaking
few eggs and can't become the number one
drama on television without generating
at least a little bit of off-screen
drama that's certainly the case with
NCIS the hit procedural might be popular
now but it wasn't an easy path what went
on behind the scenes to make this one of
the highest rated shows on television
that's a question worthy of its own
investigation
title troubles
few people remember it now but when NCIS
first spun off from parent show Jag in
2003 it was far from a guaranteed
success in fact CBS was worried that the
show would be overshadowed by the
Network's runaway smash CSI so CBS
called the show Navy NCIS for the first
season in order to minimize confusion
over the similar acronyms showrunner and
Creator Donald Bellisario eventually
convinced the network to drop the Navy
part because it's totally redundant the
n and NCIS already stands for Naval it's
a lot to keep track of
LAPD anniversary NCIS m-o-u-r-c
Mark Harmon's rage Bellisario abruptly
left NCIS in 2007 for a very unexpected
reason star Mark Harmon forced him out
reportedly the two tangled behind the
scenes from months over Harmon's
dissatisfaction with belisario's chaotic
management style it led to a showdown
and the network decided they could live
without Belisario who was forced to
resign the show continued with a
presumably happy Harman sitting pretty
Bellisario still got the last word
however NCIS lawsuit Angelus
given the huge success of NCIS it seems
like a no-brainer that would eventually
spawn a spin-off but the creation of
NCIS Los Angeles in 2009 actually led to
a major lawsuit that's because NCIS
Creator Donald Bellisario had a clause
in his contract giving him the right to
create the first spin-off after he was
forced off the show CBS hired Shane
Brennan to create the offshoot show
instead after years of legal wrestling
it settled out of court for an
undisclosed amount at an estimated net
worth of 250 million dollars Belisario
certainly isn't suffering either way
NCIS red
in 2013 NCIS was poised to add yet
another series to its franchise in the
form of NCIS red introduced in a
two-episode arc on NCIS Los Angeles NCIS
red was going to Star John Corbett as
the leader of red team an anti-terrorist
unit within NCIS one ncist league is it
enough the network decided they didn't
really dig what they saw in the backdoor
pilot and the series was canceled before
it ever began instead the network
launched NCIS New Orleans
Don Johnson almost
Mark Harmon has been the face of NCIS
for well over a decade now but viewers
could have actually seen a very
different face in the role of agent
Leroy Gibbs that's because the role was
actually offered to Don Johnson first
and he turned it down he wasn't the only
candidate though rumor has it that NCIS
New Orleans star Scott bakuluff was also
on the original shortlist where agent
gives way back in the day since
Bellisario and Bakula had previously
worked together on Quantum Leap by the
time NCIS New Orleans came along the
showrunners knew the right man for the
job was bakiba because he spectacular
[__] [__] Holly Perez Twitter blunder
in 2013 actress Cody de Pablo who played
fan favorite NCIS agent Ziva Devi
abruptly announced her departure from
the show it was a surprise not only to
fans but to her co-stars around the same
time hered posted a tweet of herself
wearing a shirt she received in 2007
which said I love my job
seemed innocent enough but it set off a
minor Twitter war with de Pablo's fans
who saw it as an attack allegedly the
Pablo called peret to ask that she
stopped tweeting about the situation
heret shut down her feed for less than a
day she should have just worn the shirt
instead
Brett's personal life while Perez has
clearly been the subject of real world
drama she's done her best to turn lemons
into Lemonade by using her position as a
platform for advocacy in 2006 she
revealed that her former husband Francis
coyote Shivers had subjected her to
years of physical and emotional abuse
and just in 2015 after she was randomly
attacked by a mentally ill homeless man
she began championing the rights of the
homeless just to be really super
grateful to be alive but the other part
is that like my heart breaks for that
guy and edit breaks for every single
person that's out there on the street
she's also stood up for marriage
equality and even reported music with a
positive message for victims of abuse
Diane Neal's Twitter meltdown in 2015
guest star Diane Nia launched an angry
Twitter attack on NCIS New Orleans upset
over safety issues she encountered on
set while filming Neil called the show's
production dangerous and stupid saying
stuff like they just used me like a
rented mule and these folks don't give a
damn didn't go over well behind the
scenes Neil apologized and deleted
tweets some sharp-eyed folks on Reddit
captured the drama and preserved it for
posterity however moral of the story
ever tweet angry a very important cameo
with three different shows and more than
20 combined Seasons the NCIS franchise
has had a lot of high-profile guest
stars but none of them can quite match
the star power of First Lady Michelle
Obama who appeared as herself on the
series in early 2016. her appearance was
made in support of joining forces a
nationwide initiative supporting service
members veterans and their families kind
of makes that time Taylor Swift showed
up on CSI seemed pretty lame by
comparison
[Music]
Lucas Black knows how to make an exit
and so does NCIS New Orleans heads up
Major Spoilers ahead during the sixth
episode of season six called Matthew 5 9
Black's character special agent
Christopher LaSalle died after
sustaining gunshot wounds to his arm and
stomach while on a mission to avenge the
death of his brother it's not easy to
say goodbye to a key character after six
seasons but it's comforting to know that
black reportedly didn't depart from NCIS
New Orleans on a whim or because of Any
behind the scenes drama no one knew
about instead black exited the
procedural for a very important reason
to spend more time with family in a
video uploaded to NCIS New Orleans
YouTube channel black who's married with
three children explained his decision to
part ways with the CBS series he
admitted that while the show has been
quote so good to him over the years the
schedule wasn't always easy there's a
lot of priorities in my life that get
sacrificed for me to be here but it's
time for me to focus on those priorities
it may be tough for fans to accept a
beloved star has other priorities but
nothing but love and support has
surrounded Black's dramatic exit from
the show according to TV Insider the
NCIS New Orleans showrunner said in a
statement we had an amazing run with
Lucas Black and he has been such an
important part of our NCIS New Orleans
team we are sad to see him go but happy
he will have more time to spend with his
family high-profile Stars might
sometimes use family as a fake excuse to
exit in an unwanted situation but
Black's co-workers seem convinced that
his reasons are genuine CCH Pounder who
plays medical examiner Loretta Wade said
in a video released by the show that
black wasn't all that concerned with the
idea of being a Hollywood star the most
important thing is to be a family man
and I think he's chosen that over all
the other choices black who according to
CBS earned his first film role when he
was 11 has mainly worked on NCIS over
the last six years Newsweek previously
speculated that black might be leaving
the show to free up time for other
on-screen Ventures like future
installments of the Fast and the Furious
franchise in which he plays tokyo-based
American Street racer Sean Boswell black
last appeared in 2015's Furious 7 and
was also in 2006's the Fast and the
Furious Tokyo Drift rumors of his
casting in Fast and the Furious 9 have
swirled for several years but black was
also expected to appear in the eighth
movie in the franchise and didn't while
it's not clear yet whether black will
appear in Fast and Furious 9 it's also
unknown whether any movie casting would
have taken him away from NCIS New
Orleans as for what's next for the actor
black didn't offer any hints about
future movie roles in his own video
posted to Twitter after the death of
LaSalle instead he chose to focus on
expressing gratitude for fans for all
their love and support celebrate the
victories and to pick me up when I
needed it and I appreciate that
the actor also indicated he would miss
playing LaSalle and remains incredibly
thankful for the time he spent on NCIS
New Orleans he went on to say that he
quote learned a lot about what the First
Responders do and that he supports and
respects the military what a great
journey it was
thank you guys so much may God bless you
so far much of NCIS New Orleans season
six has been about LaSalle's search for
his missing brother whom he then
discovers is dead and his team's
attempts to help him in his quest it's
not clear where that plot will go after
LaSalle's death and a preview of the
next episode of the show excitingly
titled boom boom boom boom only teases a
new storyline involving bombs in the
city however NCIS New Orleans star nikar
zodigan who plays special agent Hannah
Corey promised that LaSalle's character
would have a major effect on the show
LaSalle's character was such a big
important character to the show it does
have a big impact on the team in terms
of not just the relationships but
personal stories star Scott Bakula who
portrays supervisory special agent
Dwayne King Pride also revealed that
LaSalle's death means change for NCIS
New Orleans we're off on a big dramatic
change in our in our world here for
season six while the NCIS franchise is
still going strong ratings for NCIS New
Orleans have sadly been declining
according to TV by the Numbers though
it's likely upsetting for fans of the
actor LaSalle's exit just might give the
show a shot in the arm for fresh plot
lines for the rest of the season and
Beyond
[Music]
well the time has come Paulie peretz
Abby shooter has now left the NCIS team
on May 8th episode Abby finally decided
to pack her bags and head off to start a
new life in London after enduring a
gunshot wound and facing down the person
responsible for her attack all alone
fans have been bracing for the
character's accent for months and yet
it's still a little hard to accept that
her time on the show is through there
have been a lot of rumors surrounding
Polly perrette's decision to leave NCIS
after 15 Seasons but the actor is doing
her best to dispel all of them when
peret first announced in October of 2017
that she'd be giving up her long-lived
role as Abby the team's intelligent and
eccentric forensic specialist fans
wondered why she might step away from
the career-making role after spending so
many years in those Doc Martens false
rumors swirled that she was going to
become a spokeswoman for a skin care
line but Barrette shot down that story
right away and I'm like what is going on
in a note to fans the actress confirmed
her exit but denied the Cosmetic
Connection by writing so know it is true
that I am leaving NCIS after this season
there have been all kinds of false
stories as to why no I do not have a
skin care line and know my network and
show are not mad at me that might have
cleared some of the bizarre rumors about
her decision to leave after all she's
certainly not the first actor to leave a
hit series to pursue other projects but
the speculation still continued this
time Buzz suggested that trouble had
been brewing behind the scenes and that
the actress could no longer tolerate it
however it's since become clear that
peret departed on good terms NCIS
executive producers George shank and
Frank cardea told variety that they had
known for some time that season 15 of
the series would be peret's last and
that everyone involved on the show
wanted to give her a memorable send-off
the pair said in a joint statement from
day one she has brought incredible
passion and specificity to the role Abby
is a character that inspires millions of
fans around the world and all of us at
NCIS are appreciative of Paulie for
portraying her peret herself later spoke
up to assure fans there wasn't any drama
behind her departure as she told TV
Insider I believe in God in the universe
so firmly and it just suddenly became
blindingly apparent that now was the
time after a lot of thought I decided to
announce it myself on Twitter because I
didn't want it to be turned into
anything shocking Abby leaving is more
than a cheap TV Floyd paret may be
missing from NCIS in the future leaving
ducky and Mark Harmon's Leroy Gibbs as
the only remaining original cast members
but the mark she left on the series and
the impact she had on its fans won't
soon be forgotten Abby has been this
incredible role model for young women
thousands and thousands and thousands of
young women that have been inspired by a
television character and now they truly
are out there changing the world so even
though fans have said goodbye to Abby
shooter on the show her cultural impact
will certainly continue
NCIS Los Angeles has dropped a bombshell
Renee Felice Smith's Nell Jones is
planning to leave potentially for good
at the end of the show's 11th season but
what's the real reason now will no
longer be part of the show
on the episode entitled fortune favors
the brave Nell's reason for wanting to
leave is revealed the job has changed
her so much that she even struggles to
get out of bed in the mornings to come
to work she confessed as much to Kenzie
Bligh early on in the episode I don't
think I want to be an Asian anymore
okay
um
Kenzie tried to suggest that Nell rather
stick to her old base of Ops rather than
going out into the field as an agent but
that wasn't the solution Nell was
looking for either
counts I'm gonna resign from NCIS
though Kenzie suggested a holiday and
was supportive of Nell's confliction and
struggles she was somewhat less
supportive of her desire to resign from
the team
to be fair the job now wants to leave
behind is a tough one with plenty of
grief and stress involved
[Music]
between that and the personal troubles
Nell has endured with her mother's
illness it's completely understandable
that she's having serious doubts about
her job right now Nell was previously
touted to be taking over from operations
manager Hedy Lang who has also been
fairly absent on NCIS Los Angeles
recently she seemed like she'd be the
perfect fit for the job but just a few
episodes ago Nell's future on the series
suddenly became unclear instead of
pushing to keep nail in the fold Hedy
indicated that she was instead now
looking at Callan to take over for her
when the time comes Petty being heady it
seems she was well aware that Nell's
inner turmoil would probably lead her to
walk away from the job opportunity
now
be gone the episode closed with Nell
finally telling Hedy that she was
resigning but the ever stoic operations
manager gives her another option before
she makes her final decision in hedy's
view Nell is free to leave if she wants
but first she's going to have to burn
through a few weeks worth of unused
vacation days if I don't hear from you
once they've elapsed
you can consider yourself
resigned that unused vacation time
indicates that nail may well be
suffering from a serious case of burnout
between working as hard as she does and
spending time at her sick Mother's
bedside Nell's head is likely spinning
too fast in every possible Direction
which could easily be the cause of our
high stress levels and lack of desire to
go to work
when Nell walked away to tell Eric about
her decision she stopped for a moment to
look around the office seemingly saying
goodbye to the place that had been a
second home for her for almost a decade
her relationship with Eric also seems to
have suffered lately with the pair
appearing to have communication issues a
relationship between Eric and Nell was
long hoped for by ncisla fans who
noticed their flirtations early on and
hope to see them seal the deal it looked
like the relationship was finally
confirmed but season 11 has brought them
some unexpected troubles episode 19 saw
Nell desperately trying to avoid talking
to Eric at every turn something that's
not usually a good sign in a
relationship when major decisions are
being made
are you avoiding me what and even though
there have been hints of Eric also
waving goodbye to NCIS the turmoil
between him and Nell might instead see
the couple split actor Barrett foa's
time away from the show during the early
episodes of season 11 were to allow the
actor time to appear in a play his
return to the small screen in the op
Center has seemed to be fairly permanent
despite him previously looking for jobs
in San Francisco where Nell's mother is
being treated
Nell isn't in the preview for season
11's 20th episode if she has decided to
leave will fans get a chance to see her
again or has she already disappeared for
good like many other TV shows have had
to do recently ncisla has had to cut
production on the current season short
instead of the usual 24 episodes of
season 11 fans will only get 21. this
could mean that the uncertainty around
Nell's decision may be dragged out even
longer than originally planned if her
vacation days haven't elapsed by the
time the truncated season reaches its
end so far Renee Felice Smith hasn't yet
made an official announcement about
leaving the show but a recent Instagram
post of hers directed fans to tune in to
see a wistful nail on Sunday night the
studio hasn't confirmed that she's
definitely departing the team leaving
fans no option but to keep on watching
to see where Nell ends up
as the saying goes behind every great
man is a great woman in the case of
ncis's Special Agent Leroy Jethro Gibbs
played by Mark Harmon that woman is his
first wife Shannon portrayed by Darby
stanchfield we only see Shannon Gibbs in
flashbacks on NCIS as she and their
daughter Kelly were killed in a car
accident arranged by a drug dealer that
took place over a decade before the show
is set so even though NCIS seems to be
playing whenever you turn on the TV
Stansfield Shannon isn't as familiar as
some of the other characters however
there's a good chance you'll know
stanchfield from somewhere else here's
why Shannon Gibbs from NCIS looks so
familiar NCIS has consistently ranked as
the most watched drama in the U.S but
it's far from the only hit show
stanchfield has been involved with one
of her very first TV jobs was on an
episode of Angel the spin-off of beloved
Supernatural drama series Buffy the
Vampire Slayer stanchfield also had a
small role on everyone's favorite box
set of the double odds 24 playing
Mandy's ill-fated neighbor Sherry
elsewhere in the early to mid 2000s era
of her career stanchfield popped up on
that 80s show monk it's all relative
strong medicine without a trace and Nip
Tuck just before landing her NCIS gig
the actress secured a job on Jericho
cbs's post-apocalyptic action drama that
ran for just two seasons before it was
canceled stanchfield portrayed April
Greene a doctor at a medical center in
the fictional town of Jericho Kansas her
stent lasted just over a dozen episodes
with her character's Arc ending in Death
from there stanchfield took over the
character of Amelia Joff on General
Hospital for 10 episodes in 2007 and
then booked a recurring role on the
iconic drama series Madman she played
Helen Bishop The divorcee Who
scandalized 60 Suburbia for five
episodes on the first two seasons of the
series
of course if he does Dimes that
I'm joking
it took a while for stanchfield to land
another character who came back for more
than one episode but she worked
consistently on many well-known shows
she has had one-off appearances on Bones
Private Practice The Mentalist Ghost
Whisperer and even How I Met Your Mother
on which she played the snobby former
tenant of Marshall and Ted's apartment
after booking NCIS stanchfield doubled
down on the crime angle with two
separate roles on CSI New York and CSI
Miami you may also know her as Richard
Castle's first ex-wife from the comedic
crime series Castle having popped up for
one or two episodes of numerous hit
shows stanchfield landed another major
recurring role in 2012. on the Shonda
Rhimes created political thriller series
Scandal the actress played Abby Whelan
the outspoken former press secretary and
chief of staff at the White House and
the mostly loyal best friend and
colleague to carry Washington's Olivia
Pope stanchfield also got the chance to
influence Olivia Pope's World off screen
she created and directed her promotional
web series called Scandal Gladiator
wanted which was released a week before
the show's season six premiere she must
have impressed the showrunners because
she later got the chance to direct an
episode of The Final Season the 15th
episode entitled The Noise if you're
more into Supernatural demons than
lawyers you may know stanchfield from
her most recent role she played Nina
Locke on Netflix's adaptation of the
graphic novel series lock and key which
hit the streaming platform on February 7
2020. stanchfield plays the mother of
three children who returned to their
father's childhood home after he is
killed the fun and fright starts when
they find mysterious keys that unlock
Supernatural portals and attract a
demonic Force Nina Locke is also an
alcoholic which gives stanchfield an
emotional new challenge to tackle in the
role although Netflix hasn't confirmed
anything yet the ending of lock and key
hinted that there could be a second
season meaning stanchfield could be back
for more Spooks and scares either way it
looks like stanchfield's long-running
career isn't slowing down anytime soon
with a strong cast and compelling story
lines it's no wonder why NCIS has
managed to become one of the longest
running scripted Series in television
history the CBS Mega hit just wrapped up
its 18th season and the series shows no
signs of slowing down anytime soon there
will be plenty more crimes that require
solving for at least a bit longer as the
network has already picked up the police
procedural for season 19. but just
because the show is coming back doesn't
mean that there aren't going to be some
major shake-ups along the way the main
cast members tend to stick around for a
while with actors like Mark Harmon and
Sean Murray being there from the
beginning however other actors have
jumped ship over the course of the
show's long run with their characters
moving on with their lives to do
something else Beyond investigating
crimes and that appears to be what's
transpiring with Emily Wickersham who's
played fan favorite character Eleanor
Bishop since season 11. the season 18
finale saw Eleanor undertake a secret
mission but it was unclear to some fans
whether she would return or if this was
the end the actress took to Instagram to
confirm her her departure from the
series writing hang in this hat and
jacket up what a great ride it's been
it's awesome
it's been it's been really wonderful and
fun she genuinely seems to have enjoyed
her time on NCIS and there doesn't
appear to be any bad blood between her
and any other cast members in other
words this doesn't seem to be the kind
of falling out that's alleged to occur
at the time of Polly perrette's exit
from the series given the fact Eleanor
tells Nick Torres she won't be back for
a long time it doesn't seem likely that
Bishop will be coming back for any
cameos anytime soon with that
unfortunate news in mind here's
everything you need to know about why
Emily Wickersham is leaving NCIS the
actress announced her departure from the
series with an Instagram post on May 26
2021 throughout wickersham's lengthy
comments on the matter she doesn't
mention anything about why she chose to
leave after season 18 of NCIS the most
likely explanation is that she merely
wanted to pursue other opportunities
after playing the same character across
eight seasons and 172 episodes I mean if
we worked like regular nine to five jobs
things could be different being free
from the rigors of a network Show's
shooting schedule would give her
flexibility in choosing other jobs or
even just taking a break for a while and
enjoying her hard-earned success but
what's most important for fans of NCIS
is that it appears as though she's
leaving on good terms with everyone she
worked with over the last decade they're
loose like the whole cast and Crews like
Lucy goosey which makes for like such a
nice work environment it really does as
she mentions on Instagram I've been
lucky enough to be a part of a show
where I got to show up and act and laugh
and learn with wonderful people a moment
in time I surely won't forget thank you
CBS and NCIS for including me in a part
of television history as you go down her
post you can see a slew of comments from
her many followers have already come in
including one from the official CBS
Instagram account which posted thanks
for making history with us wickersham's
co-stars including Maria Bello and Brian
dietzen also use their accounts to
express their pleasure of getting to
work with her for so many years
wickersham's now free to pursue whatever
projects interest her the most from here
on out while it's still unclear where
she'll end up bright things are
inevitably in store for The Talented
actress wickersham's co-stars aren't the
only ones sad we won't see any more of
Ellie Bishop eating snacks while putting
Clues together NCIS fans took to Twitter
and droves to express their sadness at
the season 18 finale spelling the end of
Ellie as well as the much-loved
relationship between Ellie and Nick
Ellie Bishop served as an inspiration to
plenty of viewers including one user who
raved about both her favorite character
and The Talented actor who plays her
writing maybe some people will never
understand why I'm so devastated but I'm
31 years old I grew up with NCIS but I
just connected with one female character
Emily Wickersham played Ellie Bishop a
powerful talented persevering and
empowered woman others talked about how
Ellie had impacted their lives beyond
the small screen influencing the real
world in a very real way one person
wrote thank you Emily Wickersham for
creating such an amazing character one
that inspired me to pursue a career in
intelligence myself fans will miss you
but I think I speak for all of us when I
say there's only only one Ellie Bishop
[Music]
NCIS has stood Head and Shoulders above
most of its police procedural peers for
years thanks to its lovable cast of
eclectic characters and almost uncanny
longevity the CBS show has been running
since 2003 and the ongoing season 19
finds a series as strong as usual
however it's clear that the show's
arguably most massive change yet is on
the not too distant Horizon and it's
been looking that way for a while for 18
years the stalwart leader of the titular
investigation team in NCIS has been led
by Leroy Jethro Gibbs played by Mark
Harmon who was the backbone of the show
throughout its first 18 Seasons season
19 of NCIS has revealed that new
developments along with 18 seasons of
hard-hitting Investigations weighing
down on his broad shoulders have caused
Gibbs to decide that he's done with his
NCIS job and that he's planning to carve
a new life for himself on Alaska it's an
understandable development for the
character for anyone who watched the
season 18 finale the episode showed
Gibbs boarding a boat that wasn't
destined to last long as it sailed out
to sea it unexpectedly blew up
fortunately van saw Gibbs body not long
afterward Within soon swimming ashore it
let everyone know Gibbs would return for
season 19 but it definitely gave the
impression he wasn't going to be around
much longer but what exactly caused the
character to decide so or rather what
prompted Mark Harmon to join the many
actors who have left NCIS The Hollywood
Reporter States Mark Harmon's exit from
the show is a pretty final one at least
in his starring capacity after all the
star is only signed for a limited amount
of episodes for season 19 and gives his
decision to remain in Alaska pretty much
removes him from the fabric of the show
for the foreseeable future what's more
the ongoing season features some brand
new star power in the form of Katrina
law and rumored Carmen replacement Gary
Cole Harmon's limited episode deal means
that Gibbs has effectively left his
active role in the show behind but
showrunner Stephen D binder is quick to
note that the actor will maintain a
behind the scenes role and there's
always a chance for an on-screen
comeback as well finder stated as an
executive producer and dear friend Mark
continues to be an integral part of the
fabric of the show our North Star has
always been staying true to our
characters and that truth has always
guided the stories we tell and where
those characters oh so regarding the
future of Gibbs as longtime fans of the
show may have noticed over the years
never count Leroy Jethro gives out that
means viewers may not have shed their
last tears over Gibbs just yet if we
were into betting we'd be willing to put
down money on Mark Harmon returning for
the series finale whenever that occurs
it's hard to say goodbye to a beloved TV
character especially one who's been on
the air for nearly two decades Leroy
Jethro Gibbs starred in hundreds of NCIS
episodes and has earned a special place
in people's hearts the show just won't
be the same without him and fans have
already taken to social media to let
their thoughts known on the emotional
departure it's entirely possible his
final scene of fishing on a lake in the
great unknown will be the last time
audiences see Gibbs but at least he
received the send-off he so richly
deserved fans were quick to chime in
with their thoughts one fan wrote I'm
sad Gibbs is leaving NCIS I got to
respect and applaud Mark Harmon for his
performance through 18 years as gifts
another fan noted I just learned Mark
Harmon is leaving NCIS and I'm in
complete shock I grew up with NCIS and
especially with agent Leroy Jethro Gibbs
but he did his time and I'm really proud
he had such an amazing journey Gibbs has
certainly come a long way ever since he
first graced people's screens on the
episode Ice Queen on JAG it only appear
on one more Jag episode before spinning
off into NCIS where he's been ever since
Harmon walked away when the time was
right just like the great Gibbs so
famously said when the job is done walk
away
NCIS new orleans's newest special agent
Tammy Gregorio has quickly become a
favorite with fans some of whom were
surely left wondering where they'd seen
actress Vanessa ferlito before put your
hands up
now NCIS New Orleans definitely isn't
for Lito's debut here's where we've seen
this brooklynite before
24. ferlito scored an early breakout
role on the hit Fox crime drama 24
appearing on 11 episodes of the show's
third season as Claudia Hernandez Hector
Salazar's girlfriend and secret lover of
the show's protagonist Jack Bauer played
by Kiefer Sutherland Claudia agreed to
help Bauer in exchange for passage out
of Mexico but she was killed in the
process according to ferlito Claudia
wasn't originally supposed to die and
she and Jack would have ended up
together but her character was killed
off after ferlito was cast in the 2005
Tommy Lee Jones crime comedy called
Man of the House
given the movies abysmal nine percent
Rotten Tomato score ferlito may have
ended up wishing she'd stayed on 24.
then again ferlito may have taken some
small comfort from the fact that her
performance in man of the house was one
of the few things in the critical and
Commercial dud to earn positive notice
while strenuously urging potential
viewers to stay away variety noted that
she stood out Among The Ensemble
supporting Jones mainly because she's
the only one who gets enough to do to
make a strong impression as a
distinctive personality
Spider-Man 2. like most hard-working
actors ferlito has occasionally appeared
in projects that only featured her
briefly take for example her part in
2004's Spider-Man 2. in the superhero
sequel for lito played Louise Mary
Jane's best friend and shopping partner
it's a small part but at least for lito
fans can enjoy this extended scene
featuring her chatting with Mary Jane
that was edited out of the theatrical
cut what about that perfect kiss you
said you had once the guy you believe
that was a
was a Shadow Boxer in 2005 ferlito
landed a role as Stephen dorff's
pregnant wife in the crime Thriller
Shadow Boxer and like her other big
screen feature that year man of the
house it was critically panned slant
dismissed it as quote a faux Art House
crime Thriller and the closest
approximation the movies have offered
audiences this year of feeling trapped
inside a rancid toilet bowl at some
pretty scathing criticism but ferlito
was hardly the focus Shadow Boxer had
some Far bigger names attached including
Academy Award winners Cuba Gooding Jr
and Helen Mirren CSI New York NCIS New
Orleans isn't the first Prime Time crime
drama to prominently feature Vanessa
ferlito that honor goes to CSI New York
ferlito appeared on 26 episodes of the
long-running spin-off series before her
character Aiden Byrne was murdered she
later claimed that it was her decision
to leave telling TV Guide I had no
intention of doing an hour TV show I
just wrapped the movie man of the house
with Tommy Lee Jones so it's not like I
had nothing going on but it was CSI New
York you don't say no to that
Death Proof for Lito's first few big
screen roles may not have turned out the
way she'd hope but all that early
experience paid off in 2007 with a part
in Quentin Tarantino's Death Proof
ferlito played Arlene AKA butterfly one
of three friends killed by stuntman Kurt
Russell and his Death Proof stunt car in
an interview with aced magazine she
claimed Tarantino wrote the role of
butterfly specifically for her ferlito
is responsible for one of death proof's
most talked about scenes in which
butterfly gives stuntman Mike a lap
dance she told Ace people still go crazy
over that lap dance it has a cult
following now
Medea Goes to Jail
after working with Quentin Tarantino
ferlito stepped in front of the cameras
for a different sort of auteur playing a
heroin addicted prostitute named Donna
in Tyler Perry's Medea Goes to Jail for
lito later told Trailer Addict she loved
working with Perry specifically because
she appreciates working with directors
who are also actors like most of Perry's
directorial efforts Medea Goes to Jail
prove profitable at the box office so
it's safe to assume that more than a few
NCIS New Orleans viewers recognize for
Leto from this big screen hit
Wall Street money never sleeps sharing a
few minutes of screen time with Michael
Douglas and Shia LaBeouf ferlito
returned to theaters in 2010 with a
brief supporting role in Oliver Stone's
Wall Street money never sleeps in
Stone's Wall Street sequel inspired by
the 2008 financial crisis ferlito plays
a character named Audrey a tough
no-nonsense type it's a role that the
Brooklyn native was uniquely well suited
for
Stand Up Guys
those who saw 2012 stand-up guys
starring Al Pacino and Christopher
Walken likely remember for Leto as
Sylvia the woman the protagonist find in
the trunk of their stolen car the film
subplot involving ferlito's character
didn't help stand-up guy's critical
reception as the victim of brutal abuse
her role moved the plot though not
everyone felt her character was treated
with sufficient respect Time Magazine
put it like this it's nice that the
stand-up guy's rescue and Adventure but
her suffering is trivialized in a
grossly insensitive way
Graceland ferlito returned to her
television crime drama roots in 2013
joining the cast of USA Network's
Graceland as FBI agent Catherine Charlie
DeMarco throughout the series three
season run to prepare for the intense
role for lito told pop sugar that she
sat down with a number of real
undercover agents to discuss what the
job is actually like though she looked
to real-life agents for inspiration for
lito said she didn't study other actors
when I jump into a role I just kind of
go fresh I just jump right in because
you can't focus on what other people do
or then it's just not natural Graceland
benefited greatly from ferlito's natural
affinity for Crime dramas which is
ultimately the genre in which the
actress truly shines as NCIS New Orleans
fans can certainly attest
in April 2020 the long-running CBS crime
drama NCIS wrapped up its 17th season
after all these years the cast is still
headed by Mark Harmon as special agent
Gibbs and the 17th season saw
appearances from classic characters like
Ziva David and Jimmy Palmer played by
Cody de Pablo and Brian dietzen
respectively obviously the NCIS team
that we first met in 2003 has changed
quite a bit over the years other than
Mark Harmon David McCallum is the only
series regular who's been around since
the very beginning he plays Dr Donald
Duckie Mallard as you probably know but
few former NCIS characters are missed as
much as Michael weatherly's Tony DiNozzo
people just love tuning in to watch his
Antics every week really yeah I think
it's even a rule rule 38.
[Music]
oh so it's no surprise that many fans
were downright disappointed when he left
the show at the end of season 13. his
departure left us with two burning
questions one why did Weatherly decide
to hang up his badge after 13 seasons
and two will Tony DiNozzo ever make
another appearance on NCIS it's hard to
say remember what happened in the season
13 finale Tony was mourning the alleged
death of Ziva with whom he'd always
enjoyed a loving but complicated
relationship after ziva's supposed death
Tony learns that she'd given birth to
their child a secret she decided to keep
from Tony to avoid complicating their
lives talk about an emotional burden
though Tony is understandably shocked by
this news he takes to fatherhood quickly
by the end of the episode ziva's alleged
killer has been taken down by the team
and Tony has made a really tough
decision he's going to step away from
NCIS to raise his daughter and rebuild
his life of course everyone is
devastated by his departure but they
certainly understand his reasoning it's
one one of the most emotional send-offs
in the history of the series but why did
Weatherly step away from NCIS after such
a long run ultimately he left for the
same reason that many people leave their
jobs after 13 years he felt it was time
to move on in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter he said he was burned
out by the show's taxing schedule as to
how Tony's story wrapped up Weatherly
said it really felt like a circle that
had gone all the way around and I really
felt happy with the resolution of
character and my time on the show
Weatherly left the show on good terms
with the cast and crew and he quickly
landed a role on another CBS series
while he was preparing his departure
from NCIS it was announced that he would
be the lead of a new Prime Time drama
Bull the show was somehow inspired by
The Life and Times of the decidedly
uninspiring Dr Phil he finds Weatherly
playing a psychologist Dr Jason bull the
head of a Jury consulting firm as of the
making of this video bull is still on
the air after four seasons but the
question remains will we ever get to see
Weatherly late Tony again well there
have been plenty of rumors that Tony
would be returning to the show which
began pretty much the moment he left
this speculation went into hyperdrive
during the show's 16th season that's
when it was revealed that Ziva was still
very much alive and when Cody de Pablo
did indeed return to the show fans were
fairly certain that Weatherly would soon
follow suit in fact even before de
Pablo's return Weatherly hinted on
Twitter that he was totally down with
returning to NCIS writing in February
2018 yes I believe Ziva is alive and I
will always be ready to play DiNozzo
when the time is right many fans were
convinced Tony would be making an
appearance on the season 17 mid-season
finale along with Ziva and their
daughter Tali but when the episode aired
only Ziva made an appearance although
Tony and Tali were mentioned in the
episode frankly we're still waiting to
see whether Tony DiNozzo will ever make
his Grand return to the show don't let
down the team DiNozzo
yeah
it wasn't until late in the first season
of NCIS New Orleans their viewers met
ATF agent Sonya Percy played by Tony
nominated actress shelita Grant once she
became a regular on the show in season 2
she quickly became a favorite thanks to
her pension for calling out BS in her
great chemistry with aging Christopher
LaSalle played by Lucas Black as anybody
who watches Network crime procedures
will tell you all good things must come
to an end and no NCIS agent is forever
after three seasons on the show Grant
decided to hand in her badge and the
character of agent Percy was retired
anytime an actor leaves a hit show it
always raises the question was there
ouster a natural progression of the
story or was something going on behind
the scenes coming in with some attitude
uh let me lighten that load for you hey
to spoil a party but we gotta talk
throughout the fourth season of the show
it was cleared to the NCIS New Orleans
team that something was eating at agent
Percy she seemed restless and distracted
and made a few bad calls that were out
of character and her penultimate episode
on the show Welcome to the Jungle Percy
revealed that She interviewed for a
position with the FBI her issues it
seems were caused by a nagging feeling
that she needed to move on to something
new although she was offered the FBI job
Percy initially declined it as she
didn't want to upset her NCIS Squad
mates in Percy's final episode high
stakes she and agent LaSalle were
assigned to work a sting operation at a
poker game Percy ended up in an SUV with
the purp they were tracking and in a
split-second decision she rolled the
vehicle to prevent him from getting the
upper hand on her it was a very risky
move that ended up paying off but it was
further proof that Percy's instincts
were being affected by her feeling of
restlessness in the end Percy realized
that the only reason she turned down the
FBI job was to avoid disappointing other
people which wasn't the correct decision
to make for herself at the end of the
episode she announced her departure from
the team when variety originally
reported on Grant's decision to leave
they cited sources who said the
departure is amicable and mutually
agreed upon between the actress and the
producers in a later report on Deadline
the actress herself claimed she was
ready to move on the year After exiting
the show Grant landed a recurring role
on the final season of Santa Clarita
diet
good afternoon everyone I'm special
agent Tess Rogers with the FBI in 2017
while Grant was still on NCIS New
Orleans she did open up about the
difficulties of transitioning from
theater to the world of prime time crime
dramas in an interview with Lenny letter
Grant said I didn't realize just how
different a procedural is I do come from
theater and I am always looking for ways
to be human and be alive and in the
moment it is challenging to do that with
a procedural she's far from the first
actor to speak up about the grind of
filming 22 episode Seasons although she
didn't cite those particular issues when
speaking about her exit it seems likely
that they played a role in her decision
to move on to different projects one of
those different projects may also shine
some light on what factors motivated her
to leave the show it wasn't just her
role on Santa Clarita diet that kept
Graham busy after she left NCIS New
Orleans the enterprising actress
launched a hair care line specifically
for black women with Type 4 hair called
four Naturals on the company's website
Grant opened up about what inspired her
to launch her hair care line she said I
found myself utterly wrecked after three
years on a television show that
decimated my natural hair and my
self-image my tight Type 4 hair was not
welcome instead the producers and hair
Department had no issue with my natural
hair suffering or falling out to comply
with the mandate to wear a ponytail with
little to no curl after quitting what
was once a dream job I told myself that
I would turn that pain into a platform
although she didn't specify would show
cause the damage NCIS New Orleans is the
actress's only three year long stint on
any series it seems likely that it's the
culprit and it seems this difficult
environment could be another reason
Grant decided to leave
I'm Gonna Miss You City Mouse
I'll miss you too country mouse
even though it's been almost 15 years
since the show premiered NCIS still has
a slot on our TV screens every Tuesday
night some faces have come and gone over
the years While others have remained the
same since day one but they all have one
thing in common this was the show that
truly brought them into the spotlight
here's what the cast of NCIS was up to
before they got the roles that changed
their lives
Mark Harmon Thomas Mark Harmon grew up
in Burbank California the youngest of
three children to former heisman-winning
football player Tom Harmon and actress
Elise Knox football was his early
passion but the acting bug eventually
hit Harman has compiled a fairly
impressive filmography in film and
television he spent a good deal of the
last 13 years as essentially the face of
NCIS anchoring the show's cast as
steely-eyed special agent Leroy Gibbs
since 2003. Harman has starred in more
than 300 episodes of the series since
its Inception
Polly Perrette
Polly Perrette was born in New Orleans
where she dreamed of one day being a
rock star she also entertained the idea
of getting into law enforcement and went
to college for criminal science I
thought it was going to be a cop
she finally did get the chance to become
a cop of sorts and she got to entertain
millions of NCIS viewers as Abby shudo
in the process Perrette was actually
introduced into the NCIS Universe during
the last two episodes of Jag the Navy
Focus show that preceded NCIS
Michael Weatherly
born in New York City Michael Weatherly
was a professional actor for over a
decade before landing the role of
Anthony Tony DiNozzo in NCIS prior to
his breakout role Weatherly built a
solid career with a variety of memorable
supporting roles including Dark Angel
starring Jessica Alba to whom he was
engaged in 2001 Weatherly has spent the
intervening years consistently acting on
NCIS and more recently with the title
role on cbs's bull his relationship with
Alba dissolved in 2003 but six years
later Weatherly married his second wife
an internist named bayana Yankovic with
whom he has two children
David McCallum
born in 1933 in Glasgow Scotland David
McCallum grew up on a diet of classical
music courtesy of his parents who
encouraged him to pursue the musical
arts himself hey you're good
of course at first acting was only a
hobby for McCallum he got a job at an
opera house as an assistant manager
performed vocal work on the radio and
finally broke into films in 1957. he
hasn't stopped since that's over 60
years in the industry which may explain
why he wears his role as ncis's Ducky
Mallard as easily as a glove it also
doesn't hurt that McCallum followed
around real life coroners to prepare for
his role as a medical examiner on the
show
Sean Murray
Sean Murray started his acting career
early his first break came in the form
of a starring role in the 1993 Disney
classic Hocus Pocus but since he's long
since lost the Vintage 90s locks he
definitely hasn't lost the deadpan charm
that made him a breakout star on NCIS
like Polly Perrette he also has a
connection to NCIS predecessor Jag
although Murray played an entirely
different character from his NCIS role
of Timothy McGee
Brian dietzen as a younger man Brian
dietzen had dreams of Hollywood success
and the 2003 musical comedy from Justin
to Kelly gave dietzen the chance to step
onto the big screen unfortunately from
Justin to Kelly is one of the worst
movies ever made but dietzen managed to
beat the odds and joined the main cast
of NCIS the following year dietzen has
now spent more than a decade in the role
of Jimmy Palmer and although he's also
appeared in a handful of films NCIS is
still his most successful and
long-running gig
Rocky Carroll
Rocky started out acting on the stage at
the Cincinnati school for Creative and
Performing Arts the first of two
dramatic schools Carol attended before
moving to New York Carol remains an
actor with great credibility on Broadway
as well as in the popcorn movie world of
Hollywood with an Abiding Love of
Shakespeare that he's held since use his
character on NCIS director Leon Vance
has appeared in all three iterations of
the series including Los Angeles and New
Orleans
Lauren Holly
raised in New York Lauren Holly
practiced cheerleading and studied
English before getting a start in acting
at the age of 20. she landed breakout
roles on All My Children Picket Fences
and Dumb and Dumber so where you headed
Aspen
California beautiful
Holly joined the cast of NCIS in 2005
and became a series regular until 2008
with additional appearances in 2012 and
2015. Holly now lives in Toronto with
her three sons and has continued working
steadily since leaving NCIS
Emily Wickersham
born in 1984 in Kansas wickersham's
Midwestern Roots play front and center
in her role as Ellie Bishop on NCIS
Wickersham is in her fourth year with
the show as of the making of this video
and it remains her major Focus going
forward she took a shot at Blockbuster
Fame with roles in I Am Number Four and
2012's gone but the mixed reception for
those films probably felt like a big
step backwards compared to the Perpetual
success machine that is the NCIS
franchise
Sasha Alexander
by all accounts Sasha Alexander was born
to be a performer she was acting in
school plays by seventh grade and on the
side she tried out ice skating singing
and dancing these days she's just about
omnipresent on our TV screen showing up
on a number of wildly successful TV
shows such as Dawson's Creek CSI friends
and Shameless in addition to her
long-running gig on NCIS it's no shock
that this great track record made her a
lock for the 2016's People's Choice
Award for favorite cable TV actress
Joe Spano
now over 70 years old Joe Spano got his
start in the business in 1973 with an
appearance in George Lucas's classic
American Graffiti but his main claim to
fame was killstreet Blues on which he
played one of the lead roles for 144
episodes as FBI special agent Tobias
fornell Spano has been weaving in and
out of the NCIS narrative since the very
beginning appearing whenever the writers
deem it necessary for the FBI to poke
around in the ncis's business
Cody de Pablo
born Maria Jose De Pablo Fernandez Cody
de Pablo was born in Chile and lived
there for 10 years before moving to
Miami she was hosting her own talk show
by age 15 which should probably make
most of us a little sad when you think
about the typical teenager's way of
passing the time
[Music]
good news guys I spent all my money
yes I can it's all terrain dummy the
actress left her role on NCIS in 2013
for unknown reasons and snagged rolls in
a couple of films including the 33 a
dramatized Recreation of a Chilean
mining disaster for now the world is
full of projects for her choosing so
there is no telling where she'll go next
everything
Lauren hawley's NCIS character Jennifer
Shepard spent her whole career working
her way up to becoming director of the
naval criminal investigative service
only to be gunned down some three years
into the top job the last fans saw of
Shepard was in an abandoned Diner
getting sentimental with fellow NCIS
agent Mike Franks her death happens
off-screen signified by a storm of
gunshots and a mostly obscured shot of
her body but we know she didn't go
quietly replacement director Leon Vance
said that the forensics from the scene
indicated that Shepard went down
fighting
she put up a hell of a fight
Holly on the other hand wasn't fighting
against her character's death and
departure from the show she joined NCIS
at the start of season three with her
character replacing former NCIS director
Thomas Morrow and appeared on a total of
48 episodes up to the season 5 finale
sometimes learning the real reason NCIS
actors left raises more questions about
the show's famous backstage drama but
unlike some of her former co-stars it
seems like Holly left on her own terms
three seasons on a show that's into its
second decade doesn't seem like a long
time in the grand scheme of things but
Holly never expected to last even that
long on NCIS in a now deleted post on
her personal website she wrote that she
initially found her way to NCIS through
her former Chicago Hope co-star Mark
Harmon who of course is best known today
as Fearless NCIS leader agent Leroy
Jethro Gibbs excited at the chance to
again work with Harman and with
legendary Creator Don Bellisario Holly
originally went up for the part that
went to Sasha Alexander but two years
later Holly was invited to join the show
with the understanding that she would be
part of a six-episodes story arc as the
new director of NCIS Holly was living in
Chicago at the time and she started
commuting back and forth to La for the
show when the creators offered to extend
the part into future Seasons Paulie and
her family moved to California not every
departure from the show has been smooth
sailing Holly however apparently didn't
have any hard feelings she wrote
I enjoyed being on the show and began
some wonderful friendships
but two years in Holly was happy to bow
out of the series saying that after
playing the same character day in and
day out for such a long time she was
bored and wanted a new challenge
ultimately she was happy with how
Shepard met her demise according to
Holly after she let the showrunners know
that she wanted out the decision was
made to kill me and boy did they about
five different ways
Ali's only exaggerating a little bit
Shepard had been diagnosed with a fatal
brain tumor before she was ultimately
taken out by a group of Assassins
NCIS continued on without Shepard and
the actress hopes the series extends its
long run even further for the sake of
the cast and crew she wrote A lot of
people depend on it for their families
for that I hope it continues forever it
probably will I think of them all often
while some actors face the unfortunate
fate of a quickly dimming career after
leaving a hit series that couldn't be
further from the truth for Holly she's
continued to flourish in both the
television and film Realms post NCIS
which should come as no surprise
considering how many screen credits
she'd racked up prior to joining the
show since exiting NCIS Holly has
appeared on series such as leverage
Lucifer and Good Witch
she's also lent her voice to the
computer animated television show The
Adventures of Chuck and Friends playing
the aptly named Holly an anthropomorphic
forklift
Holly's biggest television gig after
NCIS came in 2013 when she began
starring in the Canadian police
procedural series motive a gig that
lasted until August 2016. most recently
Holly has held a recurring role as Lynn
Harper on the political drama designated
Survivor
he's a wonderful partner he's attentive
and irreproachable and unimpeachably
correct she doesn't mean that as a
compliment on the film side of things
fans likely best remember seeing Holly
as Linda in 2015's the blackcoat's
daughter written and directed by Osgood
Perkins the film centers around two
students who are left behind at their
boarding school during winter break it's
rumored that the school's nuns worship
Satan talk that turns out to be a lot
less terrifying than the truth of the
situation
NCIS was inarguably a bright spot in
Holly's professional career even if she
did get bored of the gig after a while
but it's clear that her future is even
brighter
you can't become the number one drama on
television without generating at least a
little drama off-screen NCIS has had a
long time to create those stories the
show first premiered all the way back in
2003. here are the facts every NCIS fan
should know about the CBs series
considering NCIS is about the US
military you wouldn't expect the show to
be a big hit overseas but since 2013 no
fewer than eight NCIS movies have been
shown on British television if you're
wondering why you've never heard of NCIS
movies before don't worry you haven't
actually missed anything films like NCIS
Judgment Day and NCIS war on terror were
cobbled together by assembling
multi-episode arcs from the TV shows
into one continuous story binge watching
the old-fashioned way
NCIS is objectively one of the most
popular shows on TV right now if not of
all time and as a spin-off of Jag it's
one of the few spin-offs to outlive its
predecessor
where mosho's popularity drops off over
time that's just not true for NCIS
in its seventh season it became the most
watched scripted show on broadcast
television
10th it surpassed the only two shows in
front of it Sunday Night Football and
American Idol to become the number one
show on network TV
it's never left the top three since but
as much as viewers love it it hasn't won
very many awards the show has been
nominated for more than a dozen People's
Choice Awards and three Emmy Awards
twice for stunt performers and once for
outstanding guest actor in a drama
series it did not win any of them
Law and Order has the famous sound used
to transition between scenes these are
their stories
NCIS uses a similar sound effect
[Music]
that sound was made by NCIS Creator
Donald Bellisario personally
when the show is entering production he
knew he wanted some kind of noise to
guide the viewer from scene to scene but
he wasn't sure what so he went into a
recording studio and started messing
around with a microphone the one that
ended up getting used is just Bellisario
tapping on a mic with the palm of his
hand
Cote de Pablo left the show in season 11
which also ended the Arc of the
relationship between her character Ziva
and Tony dinoza
that left Michael Weatherly who played
DiNozzo with a lot less to do
he realized that while the show was very
good to him it was time for him to move
on Weatherly went on to helm the
documentary Jamaica man started his own
production company and landed a starring
role on bull
actor Sasha Alexander who moved on to
rizzolian Isles and a recurring role on
Shameless was part of the original cast
of NCIS when it hit the air in 2003.
acting in a single camera TV drama
involves a lot of hard work and a lot of
long hours and by the end of the second
season Alexander was tired of the grind
of portraying special agent Kate Todd
as then showrunner Donald Bellisario was
riding the second season finale
Alexander came to him in tears and asked
to be let go Belisario complied spoke on
her behalf to persuade CBS Executives to
let her out of her contract and then
killed off her character Alexander has
since said she doesn't regret leaving
but wishes it had gotten more press
coverage during her tenure
NCIS has always been an ensemble show
but there's no mistaking that the star
is Mark Harmon and for good reason he's
a commanding presence even with a
character who's a man of few words
Leroy Jethro Gibbs doesn't talk any more
than he has to and Harman can convey
more with a glance or a nod than some
actors manage with a monologue in fact
it's hard for writers especially new
ones to figure out how to write dialogue
for the character sometimes before a
script is finalized writers will do
what's called a Gibbs pass to determine
what if any dialogue can be edited down
or removed completely the show's quirky
slash genius forensic scientist Abby
shudo gets a lot of work done thanks in
part to a steady stream of a potent
caffeine-rich energy drink called calf
pal it's now a real commercially
available beverage but it's not what
actress Polly Perrette chugs when she's
portraying Abby the red stuff she's
actually drinking is tart and bitter
unsweetened cranberry juice
[Music]
foreign
T who plays Abby on NCIS is extremely
well qualified to play a forensic
scientist
a couple of decades ago she considered
becoming an FBI agent and she has a
master's degree in criminal science from
Valdosta State University in Georgia
he was even admitted into the John Jay
School of criminal science in New York
she worked several jobs to pay her way
through including as a cook on a boat
somebody who worked in the coach act
room told her about a director who was
looking for commercial actors and Polly
Perrette gave it a shot earning roles
and advertisements as well as guest
spots on TV shows before eventually
landing on NCIS
one of the perks of holding a high rank
in the real-life Naval criminal
investigative service or the U.S Navy is
the possibility of a cameo on NCIS in
2005 around the time that he retired
from the post he'd held for eight years
real world NCIS director David Brandt
guest starred on an episode as NCIS
special agent David Brandt his successor
as director Thomas betro also appeared
on the series making a brief appearance
on a 2007 NCIS episode as coffee Man Ray
Mabus served as Secretary of the Navy
from May 2009 to early 2017 a tenure
that included an appearance on a 2009
episode of NCIS as an agent named Ray
Mark Harmon not only headlines the NCIS
Flagship he's also an executive producer
for the show and its spin-off NCIS New
Orleans
that credit isn't just a perk for having
been with the franchise for so long
Harmon is a Hands-On producer he worked
closely with fellow producer Gary
glassberg to develop New Orleans
participating in decisions regarding
casting shooting locations and music
selection
in season 3 Thomas Morrow was out as
NCIS director and in came Jenny Shepard
the character shared some history with
Gibbs in that the two were once
professional Partners as well as a
couple that mirrors the relationship
between the actors who portrayed Shepard
and Gibbs Lauren Holly and Mark Harmon
years before NCIS the two were both cast
members on the 90 CBS medical drama
Chicago Hope and it's that connection
that scored Holly the role of Shepard
Holly wrote on her official website that
Harman actually reached out when they
were having trouble casting the role and
arranged a meeting for Holly with the
show's Creator Donald Bellisario she
landed the park which was initially
supposed to just be a six-episode Arc
before it turned into a three-season run
after about four dozen episodes writers
killed off Jenny Shepard because Holly
was ready to move on to other roles
Molly Perrette was a standout of ncis's
ensemble cast since its Beginnings in
2003 providing light moments as calf pal
fueled forensic scientist Abby shudo it
was both a major TV moment and a big
career move for paret when she left the
show in 2018 after more than 350
episodes you want to help me just take
it and go yeah you want to help me say
it you want to help me yes I want to
help you you can't
just after her farewell episode aired
peret tweeted out the reason why she
fled NCIS she reportedly suffered
multiple physical assaults at work
there was some animosity and negativity
stemming from an incident in 2016 when
co-star Mark Harmon brought his Pitbull
Dave to the set
according to sources that spoke with
Radar Online Dave bit a member of the
crew with such violent intensity that
the victim had to get 16 stitches Harmon
kept Dave at home after that except for
the one time when he couldn't find a dog
sitter and allowed Dave to hang out in
his onset trailer all day Perrette was
reportedly Furious that harman's dog was
back on the set and started to shout
when Harman tried to explain sources say
peret even refused to shoot any scenes
with Harman
most huge TV shows extend their cultural
impact Beyond just hundreds of episodes
offering merchandise for fans to enjoy
it's tough for an adult-oriented crime
drama to sell ancilliary items but NCIS
had cash registers ringing for a while
with cbs's website offering a version of
the show's Bert the farting hippo
novelty toy
[Music]
Parts yeah it's cool huh
Bert is a cute hippopotamus puppet based
on the one that Abby shudo kept at her
workstation but which offered a little
something extra in that it made fart
sounds just like the one seen on around
a dozen episodes of NCIS
in 2002 folk Manus a company which
produces a wide line of stuffed animal
type puppets for toy stores and gift
shops introduced a hippo which NCIS prop
Masters used on TV with little
alteration other than dubbing in farting
sounds in post-production
CBS eventually commissioned a more
accurate branded replica of Bert from
folkmanis and the toy maker added a
spiked collar and a sound box
then according to a lawsuit filed in
2014 cbs's merchandiser went around
falkmanus and sought out a company in
China to make the toys so the network
could sell them at a greater profit the
puppet company wanted more than seven
hundred thousand dollars and the suit
was settled out of court in 2016.
like any real government agency office
worth its medal the squad room and NCIS
headquarters features a Most Wanted wall
bearing the images of the worst of the
worst criminals that pose a threat to
the United States Safety and Security
over the years It's featured all manner
of criminals murderers and terrorists
some of whom are created for the show
and some real to add authenticity
once the NCIS Good Guys eliminate them
they are removed from the wall if
they're killed the most Wanted
individual gets a big red stripe across
their portrait but not all the people on
the wall are bad guys or even real guys
for a good while the face of one of the
supposedly at large criminals belonged
to Donald Bellisario creator of NCIS
connected properties are all the rage in
movies what with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the DC extended Universe
among others but they're a thing in TV
too a number of the CW superhero shows
share a common fake reality while NCIS
is also the Connecting Point for a
number of television shows past and
present
as it's been on the air for nearly 20
highly washed years now it's easy to
forget that NCIS was a spin-off of
another less popular military drama also
created by Donald Bellisario called Jag
which aired from 1995 to 2005.
NCIS itself spun off NCIS Los Angeles
and NCIS New Orleans with several actors
Crossing into the different shows
characters from NCIS Los Angeles guest
starred on cbs's Hawaii 5-0 which itself
crossed over with cbs's Magnum PI remake
that puts all of those shows in the same
universe and you could even include
Family Guy in a 2012 episode of the
Animated Series news anchor Tom Tucker
becomes an actor and lands a gig on NCIS
Mark Harmon plays himself playing Gibbs
some parts seem so tailor-made to
certain actors or they portray the part
for so long that it's almost impossible
to imagine anyone else in the role take
Mark Harmon as Gibbs for example he's
portrayed the taciturn Naval
investigator for nearly two decades and
it's the role for which he's most famous
producers originally had someone else in
mind for the role Han Solo and Indiana
Jones himself Harrison Ford according to
Amazon Ford who is experiencing a bit of
a downturn in his otherwise Stellar
movie career when NCIS was being
developed in the early 2000s was one of
the producers favored options to play
Gibbs despite Associates encouraging him
to sign on for the role he didn't have
any interest in pursuing work on the
episodic TV series and Harman got the
gig
with about 400 episodes of reliable and
satisfying television with high
production values and star power filmed
and ready to go NCIS is an attractive
option for worldwide TV syndicators it's
a particular draw in Japan where Fox
Japan promoted the debut of the 11th
season slate of episodes in January 2014
with a rerun Marathon Fox Japan aired
the first 10 seasons of NCIS in their
entirety and in order it took a full 10
days to air all 234 episodes a period
which coincided with the New Year's
holiday
the event also earned Fox Japan and NCIS
a literal spot in the record books the
stunt was a shot at the Guinness world
record for longest uninterrupted
transmission of a TV series
over 15 years into its run NCIS has had
members of its team kidnapped shot
stabbed and even blown up by terrorists
but one of the most shocking deaths came
just two seasons in here's the real
reason Sasha Alexander who portrayed
Kate Todd left NCIS after season two
we know the NCIS Team Works long hours
to catch the bad guys but the people who
make the show are also pulling very long
shifts purely in the name of
entertainment this detail slipped by
fans who are so Furious when Todd was
killed off that show Creator Don
Bellisario weighed in on what happened
behind the scenes he explained that he'd
already started working on the script
for the last episode of the season when
Alexander begged him to write her out of
the show in July 2005 a couple of months
after Todd's dramatic death aired
Bellisario shed some light on the
situation in a conversation with the
Chicago Tribune saying Sasha came in two
days before I was to leave and with
tears in her eyes she said I just can't
work this hard the showrunner admitted
that NCIS is quote a hard show to make
we work very long hours he also added
that although Alexander was technically
under contract to CBS he persuaded the
Network's brass to let her go while
Bellisario and Alexander knew what was
coming no one else knew about her
departure fans got wind that one of the
NCIS team was going to die in the season
2 finale but exactly who it would be was
kept so secret that they reportedly even
shot an alternate ending where Todd
survived we're NCIS agents McGee there's
a chance one of us might die every time
we walk through the door
Bellisario isn't the only one to ever
lend Credence to the idea that working
on NCIS could be taxing to the point of
exhaustion for some of his Stars Mark
Harmon who has portrayed special agent
Leroy Jethro Gibbs on the series for 17
grueling years has spoken in the past
not only about how difficult to Gig NCIS
can be but about how it used to be even
more so early in the series run during
the series 16th season Harman had a chat
with Entertainment Tonight in which he
acknowledged that the job isn't exactly
a walk in the park saying this is hard
to do and we miss that sometimes because
this is a happy group and we all work
hard but this looks so much easier than
it is and that's because you've got such
talented people in so many different
directions here who all get in the same
path of what they're trying to do in a
2017 interview with the talk Harman
described the early days of the series
in terms that suggest a schedule that
was nothing short of brutal saying the
first day was 21 hours we've I think
maneuvered the schedule over the years
to make it much more specific and I
think we've gotten better with that
it's interesting to consider that the
character of Kate Todd might have been a
longer lived one had producers gone with
their initial choice for the role in a
conversation with CBS News Harmon
revealed that Lauren Hawley who
portrayed director Jenny Shepard on NCIS
from Seasons three to five almost landed
the part before it was handed to
Alexander at the time that Sasha was
hired Lauren was in that mix to play
that role and the fact that her name
came back up again for the role of Jenny
Shepard did not surprise me a lot
because of what Holly has as an actress
Holly must have Boundless Energy because
when asked why she chose to depart the
series after only three seasons she gave
a much different reason she wanted to
take on different roles and was unhappy
at belisario's departure from the show
on her personal website Holly wrote I
was saddened that Don pellissario was
forced out and I missed him a lot to be
honest now that the work bug had bitten
me again I got bored with my part of the
director and the decision was made to
kill me and boy did they about five
different ways
fortunately it seems that Alexander is
more than happy with their decision to
leave in a 2012 interview with TV Guide
she reiterated that she only left
because she personally couldn't handle
the long hours people don't realize that
on a network show you make 24 episodes a
year that's 10 and a half months a year
17 hours a day it's hardcore Alexander
wasn't just thinking about the show's
impact on her work life balance at the
time she added I really firmly believe
in my heart that I would not be where I
am today I didn't want to wake up and be
in my 40s and go oh my gosh but people
don't understand taking the risk and
leaving NCIS did seem to pay off
personally and professionally two years
after her dramatic exit Alexander
married Italian director Eduardo Ponte
the couple now have two children and she
also gained a famous mother-in-law none
other than iconic actress Sophia Loren
career-wise Alexander went on to play
half of crime-solving double act Rizzoli
and Isles for seven seasons and appeared
in the showtime comedy series Shameless
Todd may have taken one for the NCIS
team but Alexander is happy that she's
no longer sacrificing her real life for
the screen
[Music]
stealing a colleague's birthday
normal workplace but it won't at the
NCIS office and DiNozzo is just the
start of the show's problems
procedural crime dramas have a way of
manipulating the reality-based aspects
of their character's jobs in order to
fast-track some of the scenes that would
normally involve a lab filled with a
team of scientists it sort of makes
sense for a TV show to speed up the
forensic process in the case of NCIS
Abby and Ducky's jobs wouldn't exist in
real life alright we don't mean that
forensic analysts and medical examiners
aren't actual jobs obviously they are
however a forensic analyst and medical
examiner wouldn't work within an NCIS
building they wouldn't have a direct
line of communication to an NCIS agent
nor would there only be one of each a
real-life NCIS field office would work
with local States or County medical
examiners and labs for forensic evidence
and each one would certainly have more
than one person working there Gibbs team
also isn't the only group of field
agents that operates in that branch of
NCIS in that case Abby and ducky would
have to keep up with Gibbs cases and
every other agent's cases if that were
true for real world counterparts the
overtime costs alone would be
astronomical for the sake of Television
it's pretty much a necessity to keep the
show's pacing Punchy and exciting
otherwise each episode would be a victim
of the red-taped glacial pace of
real-time forensic Sciences
in the very first episode of NCIS titled
Yankee white the death of a marine on
Air Force One triggers a mess of
jurisdictional complications the
ultimate question of this episode is who
claims jurisdiction over the death of a
naval commander who dies on Air Force
One do Gibbs and his team have any right
to fly away with the president's plane
in order to hold such jurisdiction okay
let's break this one down the second the
president walks off the plane the Secret
Service loses jurisdiction and it gets
handed off to the FBI but in accordance
with secnav instruction since NCIS has a
horse in this race in the form of a dead
officer joint criminal investigations
conducted with the FBI designate NCIS as
having exclusive responsibility so in
the real world NCIS actually would have
jurisdiction to take custody of the body
but does that really give them the right
to snatch the president's plane to
ensure they keep custody and if they
can't take the plane how is it that we
never hear about anyone one getting into
trouble for that stunt
when it comes to forensics
contaminations are one of the worst
mess-ups that can happen to an
investigation it's also the case that
biohazardous materials which can
possibly cause illness and contamination
are frequent flyers in a medical
examiner's field ducky who is supposed
to be the best at what he does
ought to know how not to contaminate a
forensic lab or spread unsanitary
materials excuse me
show a little respect this is a place of
peace and dignity in Subrosa ducky
potentially contaminates several areas
with biohazardous materials he meets
Abby in her lab after performing an
autopsy as he enters Abby's area we can
see he is still in his surgical gown and
there's blood smeared all over the front
blood is considered a biohazard material
and not only does bringing it out of his
lab and into Abby's increase the chances
for an infection to break loose but it
could potentially contaminate any other
evidence that is present in Abby's
workspace gross in other episodes ducky
among other investigators commits
potential crime scene contamination
through lack of proper personal
protection equipment the National
Institute of Justice explains that crime
scene investigators must have items such
as gloves booties hair covering overalls
and masks readily available for a crime
scene sweep
the team encounters their very first
multi-episode NCIS villain near the end
of season one by the NCIS season 2
finale he's still at large but we're
more curious about why a standard
criminal investigative team would
seemingly be the sole faction charged
with taking down terrorists Arie heswari
Gibbs and his agents typically take on
cases that involve far more standard
crimes than counter-terrorism in fact
real life NCIS does include
counter-terrorism efforts but that
wouldn't include a team like Gibbs the
NCIS group would probably have to
undergo a lot of extra training
dedicated to counter-terrorism that
would hardly ever come up in their
day-to-day work even after all that
where exactly is the time to get all
their other casework done if they're
going after terrorists the real-life
counter-terrorism portions of NCIS would
take on a case like Aries and it would
probably take years of dedicated work
and a lot of information sharing with
other Federal branches it's a safe story
arc especially for the era in which it
was originally aired in the Years
following 9 11 counter-terrorism and
heavily inflated patriotism flooded the
United States making this a TV plotline
that went over well with American
audiences
NCIS spent some time in hot water when
fans and critics started asking is NCIS
sexist a lot of concerns over the show's
depiction of women came about because of
Michael weatherly's character de nozzo
during the first few seasons DiNozzo and
Kate are constantly bickering about the
differences between men and women all
while plopping women into
two-dimensional stereotypical roles and
behaviors Tony how long have you been in
here long enough to know you can't sing
I haven't shaved your legs in a week in
later Seasons there's a pretty big shift
in DiNozzo and the overall tone of the
show as audiences grew tired of watching
the same prejudiced banter fans noticed
a shift in NCIS personalities around
season nine but instead of it being a
step away from their initial portrayal
in earlier Seasons which would probably
mean multiple personality rewrites the
ship was designed to allow the show's
women more depth as opposed to the
shallowness we'd previously seen
apparently rules are loose guidelines
when it comes to the NCIS workplace even
someone like DiNozzo should know when to
pump the brakes and start thinking with
his head instead of his other appendages
DiNozzo has nearly no filter when it
comes to talking to women whether it be
at work or when he's off the clock but
since what he does in his own time is up
to him we're more concerned when he's
trying to pick up women while working
cases enforced entry he and Kate are
sent to question a suspect at a base
hospital when he approaches the desk to
ask the lieutenant on duty about the
suspect he asks her out to a lunch date
so he can go through some routine
questions and this is my engagement ring
agent DiNozzo I brought my lunch
even after the rejection DiNozzo
continues to push by saying that engaged
is not technically married and implies
she's on the fence about her wedding we
cringe later in mind games he takes a
female colleague's birth control pills
and holds them in the air for her to
retrieve like she's a child all while
saying that she couldn't possibly need
them unless she's seeing someone not a
great look DiNozzo not great at all